i wonder what your thought is peter on
you know this this this culture where
it's happening in canada the us and the
uk
some have suggested we've had guests on
the show that say
you know china's got troll armies that
sew dissent they push these messages and
they're very divisive so i'm wondering
what your thoughts are yeah i think it
is a factor i think the the you know
it's simplifying it somewhat but i think
the fundamental debate is you know where
do our rights come from and people on
the left say that our rights come from
government government tells us what our
rights are and if you're somebody i
don't even want to say necessarily
conservative right-wing i think it's
just a way of viewing it the other
alternative view is that no our rights
come from god or come from the fact that
we are human beings and that we are
sovereign and it seems to me that's what
so many of these debates are about and
china i think is playing a big role they
have these troll armies that try to
pick fights and so division online one
of the things i talk about in the book
are these very wealthy uh chinese
oligarchs look red-handed yeah the book
red-handed exactly um
a lot of these oligarchs that made their
money with these state-owned companies
or these state-linked companies like
alibaba and whatnot um there's a guy
featuring the book named josiah he lives
in california he's worth 20 billion
dollars very tight with the ccp
government um and he goes on college
campuses saying there are no human
rights problems in china everything's
great but at the same time he's given a
hundred million dollars to black lives
matter causes and he talks about how
unjust america is and how you know does
he have right to do that sure but how
can you in any universe
argue that america is this horribly
unjust bigoted society and say that
communist china is a great place to live
it's it's uh uh it's interesting china
versus america is very much the same
culture war as
internally in america right yeah so i'll
give you an example of what i'll break
down what i mean
the left is willing to uh
the establishment left and many left is
a cultural leftist lie cheat and steal
to say whatever they have to say in
order to win they'll ban censor shut
down silence etc the right is constantly
trying to play by some kind of rules and
i don't mean like the establishment
right i mean the culture war right which
includes libertarians moderates post
liberals etc they're constantly saying
thing that you know it's remarkable just
to i'm not going to get into the overt
specifics but it's obvious to anybody
who watches the right is constantly
trying to have a conversation with the
left that the left is uninterested in
having right the left has asserted its
position as true and unfalsifiable and
so be it therefore but the right keeps
saying you know let's let's let's work
out a deal simple example is like you
know joe rogan and spotify they want to
ban joe rogan they want to shut his show
down so they start pulling their music
off the platform in response joe and
spotify give some concessions okay we'll
put we'll put advisories on these
podcasts but what about podcasts with
fauci are they going to include dr
robert malone in those advisories
they're not going to do it so what keeps
happening is
the freedom-loving individuals keep
conceding some points to the
authoritarian left now on the grand
international scale it's the same thing
with china china is absolutist the
communist party you oppose us you get
crushed who's that guy jack ma was that
his name yeah gone money wiped away
because how dare you right but
in the united states we don't do that to
a certain degree you'll get canceled if
you cross the line and you'll lose you
know because once again it's the
authoritarian left but because of this
power imbalance and uh
i would call it integrity and principle
imbalance china can look at someone like
lebron james and say yeah we're going to
give you 10 million dollars never talk
bad about us he goes you got it yeah
then he comes to the united states where
the left plays by a similar game and
they say
don't screw with us we are the ones who
are going to make sure your contracts
stay in but if you challenge us we'll
get them revoked so what happens america
is really bad why the left agrees and
the chinese communist party agrees right
those that are playing by the rules are
getting wiped out yeah and bizarrely
there's a consistency to that that the
united states is terrible in china is
great and in both cases you get paid you
don't pay any price really in today's
culture popular culture uh for you know
disagreeing with blm i mean you get
cancelled so the the path to least
resistance
is basically to embrace these sort of
left-wing ideas and it's the same thing
with china and you never pay a price for
it i mean as i point out in the book
with lebron james everybody knows the
recent thing about the the tweeting
about hong kong and how he was defending
them
it goes back i mean he's been doing this
for like 15 years there was a a crisis
you guys might remember back in 2007
2008 darfur
you you had in sudan you know 200 000
black christians were slaughtered in the
south by this regime the regime was
backed by the chinese government and
there was actually a petition in the nba
to call out china because they were
backing this regime that was
slaughtering black christians and lebron
james refused to sign the petition
so for a guy who says black lives matter
yeah the the guy who believes black
lives matter as we all do
those black lives did not matter to him
because he did not want to offend china
but but come on peter just just i want
you to imagine something all right yeah
it's a snowy beautiful mountain you're
up top in a big 8 000 square foot cabin
one the whole north face of the building
is one big glass window and you wake up
and you press the coffee button on your
keurig and it makes you a nice hot
cappuccino and you know you walk to the
window and you look out at this
beautiful sunset you smile to yourself
and say this 40 million cabin was worth
selling out all of those suffering
people and you sip it and that's what i
imagine is going through lebron and all
these other guys heads when they're when
they're they buy these properties and
the money is is they they genuinely
believe it's worth it well and it's
interesting that the people who are able
to afford to buy off famous celebrities
to espouse their political views are
almost all on the left and one question
i want to pose to everybody is
when justin trudeau talks about these
truckers do you think he actually knows
any do you think justin trudeau has
anyone in his life who does that
professionally
and i see it as a problem
not necessarily of income inequality but
of economic stratification so in the
past income inequality existed but you
were hanging out with people who were in
different income brackets you knew
farmers you knew plumbers you knew
people who were in the working class
even if you had an accounting job and a
lot of that was the community that was
built up at your church and i can
testify to that as well
at my church in my social group we're
fortunate enough to have all sorts of
people from different economic brackets
because we're focused on a larger
mission
but nowadays people really gravitate
towards their own in-group with respect
to wealth and then they sort of pat
themselves in the back because they
think their particular in-group because
it's left-leaning represents the views
of the working class but then when they
hear what actual working class people
have to say they lose their minds so i
think at the end of the day a question
that you need to ask yourself about any
political leader is is this a person who
would fit in better with like walmart
shoppers or whole foods shoppers and
justin trudeau is not going to fit in
with a group of people who live normal
lives he's not a whole foods shopper
he's uh what's that place called arowan
is that what it's called never been
there but it's is it called erawan i
don't know i've never heard that name
maybe
i don't know no there's a really really
really expensive uh grocery store in l.a
that all the celebrities go to
maybe i got the name totally wrong yeah
we look at it but it's like i was saying
but that's not really no no that's where
we went as kids
very expensive story it's in la and i
was i was outside once and i saw jake
gyllenhaal like walk in
and it's like that's where the
celebrities shop that's just you know
what's funny is um
yeah i think you make it really great i
know what you're talking about i mean is
it arohan
justin trudeau is the kind of guy who
like walks into a grocery store and
there's no milk and he's like there must
be a mistake where's the milk and then
they're like well the truckers have
stopped driving he's like what does that
do with the milk
well mr trudeau the truckers bring the
milk they do what and i i honestly think
that when it comes to people like
trudeau or when it comes to so many of
these woke left-wing people first of all
having those views is almost certainly
an indicator that you spend most of your
time with really wealthy people yeah and
secondarily
if you do hold those views generally
when you're dealing with a working-class
person it's because you're telling them
what to do and they have to because it's
their job and so i think that's a big
part of the reason why they're
completely unwilling to negotiate
because from their perspective they
always get to tell people in this
bracket what to do and they obey so when
they stand up for themselves they can't
stand it and that's it's not just that
they can't stand it they can't even
comprehend it it has to be racism they
have to put it in this box of some sort
of bigotry because that's the only way
they know how to analyze the world is um
is trudeau um a servant of the canadian
people like in the united states or is
he a puppet of the queen
he's a question he's supposed to be a
servant but you know it's it's it's
interesting at the heart of what you're
saying and what what you shameless were
saying earlier um there's a quote in the
book i have because the trudeau family
has this long history of relationship
with the chinese government and there's
this uh amazing question that justin
trudeau's asked in 2012 he's a member of
parliament and he's asked is there
anybody on the world stage that you as a
political figure sort of really admire
uh you know some country in the world
and he doesn't say the united states he
doesn't say great britain he says china
i admire china and they ask why do you
admire china and his answer to your
point chamber says well you know if
you're the leader of china you can just
get [ __ ] done you can get things done
you know it's efficient and he talks
about climate change and he says you
know you don't have to debate all these
things you just get things done you know
how you respond to someone like that
like if i was sitting down if i was
talking to trudeau and he said that i'd
be like you know
justin
spot on i mean when you've got a global
pandemic for instance and you can just
weld the doors shut poor people exactly
so they just die right you don't gotta
worry about a pandemic why should i get
sick let them die you know what i mean
right and it's like it's like you know i
you know look i'm trying to build a
highway for instance and these poor
people think they can own land just get
them out allow them out of the way yeah
where do they live who cares screw them
they're poor people they're not paying
taxes right right now
there's a certain efficiency to a
dictatorship and that's attractive to
justin trudeau and there's other people
that say the same thing but trudeau it's
so interesting to me because it's
exactly what you guys were saying
earlier that that he doesn't have a
connection
people become
just these objects you move around on
the chessboard right if you don't have a
connection with them if you don't if you
don't know truckers if you don't know
farmers you just they're they're things
to be moved around on a chessboard and
that's the mentality of a dictator
exactly i apologize if i was a little
snide you in my reply to you sort of
asking if if trudeau was a servant but
i also think that it's so telling that
when trudeau is looking at communist
china the person he empathizes with
is the dictator the person in control he
doesn't look at communist china right
and think about the people living there
and how horrible that would be he
immediately associates himself with the
communist dictator that's very telling
how how that doesn't end a political
career i will never know i like how
people call justin trudeau castro yeah
kind of castro like castro
well because they they ea
i mean there are people who genuinely
believe he's the son of fidel castro
right but just in terms of being a
dictator just kestrel is is is so uh on
point he was born to pierre right pierre
yeah yeah so he was basically raised
bred to be elite a leader i don't like
that that's not the right word yeah
to be a prime minister right uh
obviously
well i i think he might be a poor leader
um i agree so what so he was just
raised psychotically in that environment
yeah i mean it it's it's funny when you
look at the the family history like his
dad pierre trudeau he was the one that
opened up relations between canada and
and china
diplomatic relations and then when he
left the prime ministership and he had
been like this pro kind of mao he wrote
this like ridiculous book where he went
to china and he you know meets these uh
you know pioneer children you know like
these seven-year-old kids running around
with the red flags and they're chanting
these maoist sayings and he's saying
this is the future of the country but
when he leaves the the premiership in
canada he opens up a consultancy
helping getting businesses juiced in
with the communist leadership in china
because he had a good relationship with
him so that's where the trudeau family
money comes from
and so justin grew up very privileged
courtesy of the fact that his dad was
doing all these deals in mainland china
i had no idea that's where the family
wealth comes from yeah that's really
found
wow from a series of of deals that he
did and justin's got a younger brother
who's kind of a former policy adviser of
his name's alexander has written some
like insanely horrific things about
china
again kind of this admiration for
dictatorship people don't understand it
he says like you know canadians in a way
are less free than people in china
it's it's ridiculous stuff and and
that's sort of the background of what
justin trudeau grew up in what he heard
from his dad what he heard from his
brother and it now influences the way
that he deals with china so when he sees
truckers uh in canada you know it's not
hard to take a leap and say this is the
you know imagine how a chinese leader
would look at you know truckers in china
if they were doing the same thing he
goes you know i really wish i could just
take their organs that would be such it
would be a far more efficient country
there'd be a way better way of doing
things thank you justin do you do you
think that china is we've asked a lot of
people this is actively engaged in
sowing the conflict in our countries yes
making the culture war worse absolutely
um you know and you look at look at uh
various things you look at the donations
that some of these guys are that are
connected the regime are making they're
making donations to these divisive
groups um you look at i think the whole
question of covid i mean i'm not an
expert but you at least got to entertain
the idea uh that that it was a lab leak
but you know in congress there hasn't
been a single congressional hearing
about the origins of covid and i'm
convinced part of it is because nancy
pelosi and her family have their deals
with canada there have been hearings
that have addressed it yeah but
yeah rand paul has raised the question
but they you know to have a
congressional hearing that says we're
going to explore the origins of covet
and and lab leak nancy pelosi has
refused to allow any of them being held
on the house side the other thing i
would add is is on china is look at the
whole fentanyl you know issue absolutely
i mean where does the fentanyl come from
and it's not just fentanyl it's designer
drugs as well yeah you're familiar so
for those that aren't familiar for those
that aren't familiar designer drugs
typically are some kind of narcotic or
drug that is slightly altered in such a
way that it now is legal although good
luck explained to the cop the molecules
that i have here are slightly different
but a lot of this stuff comes from china
they are they are producing drugs and
shipping them over here illegally and
they're they're killing people yeah i
mean it's it's it's fourth and fifth
generational war it is it is indirect
but it is massively damaging the the
fentanyl problem and then potentially
the the the drugs that come here
designer drugs or otherwise could be
laced with something and cause even more
problems yes this is the reversal of the
uh opium wars it is the opium wars yeah
we're still in them yeah it's revenge
it's 100 years later 120 years later
we're still in the opium wars now
they're just feeding it back to us
through mexico yeah so well so explain
that what does that what does that mean
well you know the opium wars um uh
because of the opium trade in in in asia
the british empire and and other powers
sort of divided up they were so hungry
to get access to opium and export it
that um they took over portions portions
of china and china became not completely
but kind of a vassal state and they had
a huge drug problem in china as well
because of this demand
and then they finally gained enough sort
of national sovereignty to sort of beat
it away but you actually find literature
of
you know chinese military officers and
others saying when fentanyl comes up
well
this is revenge for the opium war was
that was that related to the boxer
rebellion
that was a part of it yeah that was part
of it but but you know china has been uh
obsessed and i understand because this
is terrible part of their history
with extracting revenge on the western
powers because they were so weakened
they were this empire uh that had been
largely defeated by the west uh and they
want revenge and you see g talks about
this all the time talks about this all
the time that that you know by 2049
they're going to be seized the
commanding heights on the global stage
they're going to you know overcome the
united states and there's going to be
payback for what the western powers did
to his country 150 years earlier so what
the then is klaus how does klaus schwab
get into this is he like
accelerating this communist insurgence
into the united states you know it's so
funny on all these guys you look at um
uh you know some like elon musk and
these guys have elon musk says some
great things and then he says some crazy
things about china about how china's
more representative than the united
states and i mean it's just crazy stuff
and you have to decide with all these
guys whether it's klaus schwab is are
they just doing it for the money
or do some of them actually believe it
and i think some of them actually
believe it i think a lot of them do it
because they want access to china they
want access to the chinese market
a guy like klaus schwab i think is a
true believer and he said you know that
that hey they've got good market reforms
in china and yeah you know it's you got
this dictatorship but that's less
important because they've got this
market that they've set up it's it's
it's crazy stuff so he's i think a true
believer he's not just doing it is it
because the i i don't the chinese bank
does it get its money from the bank of
international settlements in switzerland
as well as so could klaus and his
buddies just shut off the chinese
economy so they're really not afraid of
the chinese government it'd be hard to
shut off the chinese economy because
it's so wedded in so many ways
financially and otherwise and that's
been the thing right we were told for 30
years
for 30 years if we just traded with them
if we just gave them you know access to
our financial markets if we let them
watch our movies and you know buy our
clothes they're going to become more
like us
and no they haven't they're their
dictator we've become more like them
amen elon musk is tweeting support for
the truckers yes and there's there's
rumors going on i haven't i haven't
verified this but liar.com is reportedly
owned by elon musk i don't know if
that's true but people are claiming it
is and it links to trudeau's wikipedia
page and it's associated with a 42 000
donation i don't know if any that's true
so fact check that one but it's a viral
tweet going around where people are
claiming this yeah and maybe elon musk
is just playing uh both sides yeah it
could be and look i i think in musk's
case if i were to guess you know he's
got a big tesla factory in china they
built it for him china's a big growth
market he's saying stuff because he
wants access to the market but some of
these wall street guys they they are
true believers they they believe in
these leaders they think they're better
than ours they think the system is
better than ours um and and to my mind
they're just sellouts well can i ask you
how could they possibly believe
something like that are they genocide
deniers do they pretend that it's not
actually happening over there or do they
think that their market is so efficient
that it justifies that kind of behavior
well so i'll give you an example that
sort of blows my mind there's a guy i
don't know if you guys have heard of him
his name is ray dalio he runs the
largest hedge fund in the united states
bridgewater associates
and he wrote a book in 2017 called
principles which is ironic based on what
i'm about to tell you in that book he
talks about a the second most powerful
man in china named wonky shawn who he
says i've known him for a long time and
he says wonky sean has almost helped me
tap the secrets of the universe and he
talks about this quasi-religious
experience that he's had just meeting
with these guys this guy he's so wise
i've learned so much from him and he's
been this remarkable force for good for
like 30 years i thought well who the
hell is this wonky shanghai so i started
looking it up
he's g's enforcer he's in charge of
party discipline he's the guy that
throws people in jail and has them
tortured now why would you as a smart
guy like ray dalio
write something like that
and then you realize that he wrote that
he said a bunch of other nice things and
then his hedge fund got the first
opportunity of any other hedge fund in
the world to sell hedge fund products to
the chinese
i guess if you're if you're elite if
you're extremely wealthy you feel safe
and secure in doing your dealings yes
and then it's the people of the world
who suffer for it yes yeah if you're
elite i mean you're assuming if things
go south you're still gonna be okay your
family's gonna be saying i think you're
right yeah and uh you know not to make
any specific uh accusations about ray
dalio here right but we do know
statistically that people who trade on
wall street are actually more likely to
be psychopaths and sociopaths now i
can't give someone that that kind of
diagnosis but those are the behaviors of
a psychopath to praise somebody who
would do that kind of thing because you
think it'll get you money thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you